75 miles east of lake charles is the
city of lafayette louisiana
cbs is morning lead national
correspondent david begno is there to
report on the hurricane's effects david
good morning to you
jeff good morning to you welcome to my
hometown lafayette when we arrived here
last night one of the first things we
noticed
was this tree blocking this road which
is a main
access point to the largest hospital in
the city
lafayette general medical center the
lights are on because the hospital still
has power they are on backup power
but much like what maria is seeing about
60 miles to the west of here
most of lafayette is without power this
morning
let me tell you about our journey to get
here we left jennings louisiana last
night so
from where maria is we were about 30
miles to the east in jennings
they took a direct hit from the storm
the eye
passed right over us when gusts were
close to 100 miles per hour
there are reports of four to five homes
which have trees that fell
into them there were no reports of major
injuries or deaths the police chief by
the way pulled his cops off the road
for most of the night telling people
we're not going to be able to check on
you
until saturday morning as we left
jennings and headed east toward lake
charles
toward lafayette most of interstate 10
was open there was flooding on the sides
but nothing blocking the roadway
but when we got into the hub city which
is known uh which is how lafayette is
known i mean i'm telling you there are
trees
all over the place no reports of major
injuries or deaths here
but it is going to be a massive cleanup
effort today
and into next week before i toss back to
you a bit of a public service
announcement here
do you know that most of the deaths
reported from hurricane laura six weeks
ago
were due to carbon monoxide poisoning
people who didn't die because trees fell
on them but because they were poisoned
them and their animals
so for the hundreds of thousands of
people affected by this storm now
delta please keep your generators at
least
20 feet away from where you are it's a
lifesaver
jetpack yeah that's a great great point
david bagno thank you
very much